it looks like it could be game over for
the Democrats impeachment spectacle
president Trump's been declaring victory
on Twitter and Republicans have been
signaling that they could vote to acquit
the president as early as tomorrow
here's some highlights from the trial
today that this points to the exact
problem what's taking place here and
that is my colleague mr. sepiol Oni has
said this is really taking the vote away
from the American people but what we
have seen over the last couple days is a
descent into constitutional madness but
the vice president by his account never
once asked his son to leave the board
instead he started investigating the
prosecutor who was going after burry
smih and this corrupt oleg arc and the
reason President Trump is ready to
declare victory is over two videos that
are surfacing one from John Bolton and
the other from Adam Schiff take a look I
will be meeting President zelanski he
and President Trump have already spoken
twice President called to congratulate
President Solinsky on his election and
then on his success in the parliamentary
election they were very warm and cordial
calls we're hoping that they'll be able
to meet in Warsaw and have a few milli
given the history where we've had the
politicization of intelligence over WMD
why we would pick someone who the very
same issue has been raised repeatedly
and that is John Bolton's politicization
of the intelligence he got on Cuba and
on other issues why would we would want
some with that lack of credibility I
can't understand Wow okay so that hurts
one but let's just take a look at it
from the weak all right Democrats went
first obviously landed some punches then
the Republican defense came in Saturday
obliterated them then you have this leak
about Bolton and it looks like the
Republicans were getting a little
defensive and now as the White House
team has finished making their case it
looks like there will be a vote on no
witnesses and the president will be
acquitted on Friday maybe Saturday
morning Wow
lots of digest Williams well I mean you
know I just find so much
this upsetting but because I start with
game over well wait a second so game
over on the basis of the Bolton tape
says the president I think to myself
well if that's the case if the if Bolton
is exonerating the president why
wouldn't the president and his team want
Bolton to come before the American
people before the impeachment trial and
testify but of course we all know that's
not the case
he doesn't want both in anywhere near
this he in fact is putting up every
roadblock to stop Bolton from testifying
and he continues to refuse to release
any material so it's this all
showmanship and he's terrific at
showmanship Donald Trump can put on a
show but in terms of protecting the
American Constitution in terms of
stopping us from becoming a monarchy
with a king that answers to no one you
know I just wonder what is going on and
I think the president's been answering
to a lot of people since the day the
office he's been checked every single
day every sister Bly everybody clients
about these tapes that have surfaced it
looks like a little hypocrisy none of it
is a surprise these are these are
politicians and by nature they're going
to contradict themselves and Adam Schiff
won in 2000 he beat Jim Rogan in his
district to become a congressman because
of his outrage over Bill Clinton's
impeachment
so obviously the arguments that he made
he's now arguing against his own logic
and I understand positions can evolve
and and certainly it's it's been 20
years since he ran for that office and
and he's been stinking up Congress ever
since however John Bolton can't have it
both ways
he can't be a patriot and a compromiser
at the same time so it's it's one of the
other and I actually wouldn't mind
hearing from John Bolton I want to know
how he can square some of the salacious
things that he is reportedly written in
this book with you know is it saying
that the president was warm and cordial
so either he was he's not a patriot and
and he was just disseminating propaganda
on behalf of the president because he's
totally
reminds himself or somewhere in here
he's lying yeah so right now what do we
have few more questions and then
tomorrow what do we do tomorrow Dana
they have a few more final thoughts and
then they're gonna hold a vote then
they'll have a vote so then the vote
will be whether its kind of proceed it's
like a technical thing you gotta have
this gateway vote to see if there's
going to be witnesses and if it's clear
that that's going to fail then they'll I
think that there will be a motion to
have the acquittal vote and there's some
amendments you could do on that so it
could be a long night but I do think I
believe that Mitch McConnell has steered
the Republicans in a way that they will
be able to finish this by late Friday
night maybe early Saturday morning it
could be a really late night or an early
morning depending on your perspective I
have been surprised that nobody's
brought up the fact that in December
just a month ago the IMF the
International Monetary Fund they finally
may finally release their money to end
loans to Ukraine and if you look at the
reason that they were holding it back or
like they were concerned about it it was
all about corruption so that isn't a
surprise so it's not a surprise either
that john bolton the national security
adviser would go on Radio Free Europe
and talk about corruption in Ukraine
because it was just like a well-known
thing I would also point out that
Senator Alexander from Tennessee was
considered somebody who's got this great
reputation and he doesn't want to sully
that and he's got he's retiring the end
of this year so maybe the Democrats
thought he would vote for impeachment
over the past two days unless I've
missed something in the last little bit
he hasn't asked a single question which
makes me think he has all the
information that he needs and that the
Democrats have failed to force a vote on
witnesses and that is a contrast with
the media says the media always says
Republicans don't have enough votes to
block witnesses no it's actually what
the Democrats haven't been able to prove
their case beyond a reasonable doubt and
force a vote on and that frustrated you
know very quickly to add to that that
frustrated susan collins so she's one of
the people that you know we've been
looking to to see where she's going to
the media always trust a box republican
narrative so speaking of the media this
is Joe Lockhart saying some just really
explosive stuff about the president what
I thought when I was watching it was
this is an American
this is what you hear from Stalin this
is what you hear from Mussolini what you
hear from authority from Hitler from all
the authoritarian people who
rationalized you know in some cases
genocide based on what was in the public
interest so Alan Dershowitz being very
effective making the case for the
president and the media is going after
him big time I'm really gonna miss this
I actually hope that they don't vote
tomorrow because I'm starting to like
this a lot yes what but what the media
is doing right now is that they're
intentionally misrepresenting what
Gershowitz said Durst tertian which said
you can't be impeached for doing
something in the national interest if it
also helps your re-election because
everything you do that is good helps you
in a reelection so if you were to
impeach him about this which is about
investigating corruption in the Ukraine
you could just as easily impeach him for
introducing a Middle East peace plan or
a trade deal because that also helps his
personal interest is listen to you keep
listening you talking all day so anyway
that is why Bolton's bombshell actually
helped Trump because it enforces the
idea that trumps interest was in
corruption now if a space alien came
down and said hmm I see two sides one
side says impeach the other side says
acquit what is the difference one has
been saying impeachment for three solid
years that is the difference so that
explains the emotion that explains the
hyperbole because they put years into
this this is a sunk cost that they can't
let go now what I know what you're gonna
say so I'm gonna I'm gonna preempt you
thank you the reason why these two sides
mirror each other is because it really
is about the power of Congress versus
the power of the president right darshan
which says that if you can impeach over
obstruction of justice which is vague
that gives the Congress too much power
every Congress now can impeach a
president at a whim and there and the
president becomes a puppet the other
side says if you don't impeach him Trump
is a tyrant and a king so you see how
the argument is exactly equal the only
difference is one has been doing it for
three damn hear care about impeachment
for months
big trying so just for the audience sake
just be very clear this is not about
corruption in the Ukraine this is about
Trump seeking dirt on Joe Biden that's
just validated my point that's the point
you said oh no you said this is what
general you can't read his mind okay
you're reading is fine doesn't matter I
mean you wanted Trump's tax returns and
you asked a lot of questions about his
real estate deals because he was running
for president why isn't it okay to ask
questions about Joe Biden when he was
vice president why isn't it okay the
same line of inquiry let me get this
straight because they said this is
something the trunk
oh it's okay to get information from a
foreign government what are you asking
about yes investigation exactly in
violation of campaign finance it's done
it's literally Adi
nobody is that Joe Biden did anything
wrong about everybody said nobody even
the Democrats said now all the Democrats
were running for president against Joe
Biden no I would never have my debaters
be sold over doing what it was